[Music]
bro
bro
bro this saga
the saga can bro this is
we forgot all about this because we were
covering it
but
with everything we had going on in new
york this just totally escaped my brain
yeah we i know we were covering it when
we had the
the studio
but it's just i didn't know so he came
on well finally uh oh i remember because
we were this is when we uh yeah
we this was the night we did like the
triple header of shows yeah and zach
pulled this up and i heard
two seconds of it start playing and then
he quickly hit pause and i'm like did he
go on did he go on did he go on and
zach's like yeah he went on all right so
he went on tiger belly
which is uh bobby lee's podcast uh
brandon shoved it
and um i want to thank ladpoll on
twitter because he went through the
whole thing and time stamped so i got
time stamps so we don't even have to or
shaun probably calls it tiger billy yes
fair enough i was on tiger billy the
other day oh god he doesn't get it also
no no no no and no
[Laughter]
i love how [ __ ] i love how proactive
frozen has become he's so prevented my
favorite
all right guys
i'm gonna ease into just naturally ease
into it we don't have to get into it
right away
let's just ease into it everything's
fine okay
is it is it it's not i
was about to drive my car off the pizza
let's just ease into it well that's why
you're here because we don't want you to
do that yeah yeah so go ahead gil start
i'll just do that let me just start okay
and then and i'll introduce you it'll be
fine go ahead i'll start when you when
you guys ease into it
all right go ahead there's a calm
countdown
five
four
three three
two you [ __ ]
all right so go ahead
[Laughter]
i know you looked at it i know i have
the timestamp of when frozen wants me to
start too so trust me we're just i'm
just kind of setting up the world
setting up how this is starting we're
going to get into it don't worry we're
one faith-based podcast yeah we're the
number one faith faith faith and we
believe in all faiths um
zoroasterism
okay i am uh skipping ahead here
to the next uh timestamp let's check
this out uh
right around here
that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com and enter promo
code tiger for 20 off your purchase
today brook linden the curators of
comfort
[Music]
see frozen that's how you do a live read
for there for for your your people
let me let me let me start let me start
with this okay go ahead i love both you
guys
he loves them both dude
i think the problem is you love one of
them a little too much that's kind of
what started this now
and the other one not enough mm-hmm
both you guys
and you have always been nice to me and
that goes so far with me
because when i came to comedy i was a
tough sell man still am yeah so the
people that were nice to me i never
forget
i never ever forget ever
and i you know what um
i believe you i believe that you i
believe you um
which makes it this
a little bit difficult for me because
um
of what
you know because we're just gonna
lay it out out there um what happened a
week and a half ago um what happened
and i just want to kind of slowly get
into it you know i mean because i just
want to talk about the truth and about
and getting to the root of whatever this
problem is
the only reason i'm here is to get to
that
that and rogan was like you guys [ __ ]
figure this out you guys all look like
[ __ ] you want to be on my show again
i have an idea figure [ __ ] out
okay for us to move on it's literally
the only reason i'm here all right so
let's start with um i'm in oklahoma
i'm at dinner um
and you text me
that there's a journalist
doing an article about me
no not not not just you keep going yeah
there's a journalist that's doing an
article about
well on the text i just read it um you
said it was about me maybe
i mean you implied something else but
that's what i read
so if brendan already caught lying
number one and then i
texted you what the exact words for
um a journalist contacted me not good
for you not good for you shut up let him
tell the story
yeah yeah all right and um which got me
spinning a little bit and i for sure
texted you
what and you said you can't you know do
it through text
then um before we talked on the phone um
i had a conversation with a cohort of
mine you know um i don't want to throw
his name in there but why everyone else
is throwing everybody else's name now
we're not going to i don't want to say
names oh cohort let me guess now names
are bad yeah let's see what he said and
we'll try to guess who it was um and you
had texted him the same thing um a
mullet cohort of mine
exactly a really supportive friend who's
a nice guy with a mullet isn't isn't
that exactly where your mind went first
too with him to theo weird so anyway i
called or you called i don't forget how
that way i'm a big fan of theo vaughn
the more i see theo vaughn the more i
like him
and all of a sudden i was in a three-way
call
with you and somebody that you are
associated with um i'm not gonna
say his name and um brian callan
you can though he i don't want to
so brian callan fell on this sword brian
callan is not invited over there brian
callan is not bobby lee's friend but
brendan's job is but brendan shaw is as
complicit in this as everybody else am i
even just listening to what bobby lee
said grease ball mafia [ __ ] yeah this is
kind of weird
just so you know brian did before you go
on i don't want to interrupt you brian
did
say on firing the kid how he
royally messed up with that engagement
royally messed up
okay carry on
bobby is
[ __ ]
and by the way can i say
rightfully so
[ __ ] livid
that's an angry person
so um
but i found it to be
extremely traumatic in the in the sense
it's traumatic they're all from
california dude words are dramatic
yelling on the internet is traumatic
it's just weird like we were just
hanging out with a bunch of new york
comics and they're [ __ ] ruthless
they're not nice people that if it was
somebody that um [ __ ] they talk about
each other and i don't mean like the the
old roasting at the table the seller i'm
talking the [ __ ] they talk behind each
other it's hilarious
no um that'd be one thing but um
you know
brian and i have had a very long
relationship 30 years yeah a long time
um you know i've been to his house for
super bowl parties um we were on the
same show together not the same time but
he's a mad tv alumni as as well as i am
um
and him and i have been yeah but you're
one of the good ones yeah you're one of
the ones that has memorable characters
yeah
kindred spirit cabana boy wasn't a
favorite character of yours
you know
guys how many store guys and um
you know
so when you guys called you uh it was
you and brian and um
you said that i um that you guys my
career was going to be over um that you
guys have evidence you know i mean that
um that i'm some
reddit mastermind that there's you have
files and proof
that um you can trace you know
me from reddit back to my house the u.s
wow how though see that's the because
they hacked them in real time i want to
understand unless they know somebody
that works at reddit right
well you know um
address and that i um
have been
for five and or six years have been um
coily and and you know mischiefly you
know
you know contributing to threads that
were um not contributing what didn't you
say was
i hate her let him tell the story please
that we were responsible responsible
right
and that um
you know that you were gonna expose me
to rogan and all these people
oh boy
they use rogan a lot don't they
oh by the way can i say we were right
we were right that's one of our
predictions we look at all the clips
that we did with one of our predictions
and then i should get a lawyer and that
i um i mean this is what you told me and
it and also just
mind you
it was at a level 10 of rage it wasn't
like a soft-spoken like you know very
aggressive yeah it was extreme you know
i mean threats and then you called
kalila things i don't even want to
mention
i'll
defend him on that
i did not i know you didn't i i would i
i haven't heard what you guys said i've
i don't talk like that i would never
call clyde that that's not brendan you
called me that on the phone call we had
i
oh oh
uh oh
look i hate this [ __ ] but she's at
least got bobby lee by the balls so she
can actually speak up and be like yeah
you did though
you did do that though
oh god that's
all right all right i did not call you
that right you i did not know you don't
know what you don't know what he they
said so you can't
the stuff that i got was pretty on par
to just about what what you can tell
somebody
brian apologized what brian said on
there and even i told him that was too
that was a lot it was a lot yeah it was
a lot but what what i feel like really
just throwing all the [ __ ] brian
calling under the bus huh oh yeah he's
been backing it up on him and back over
heartbreaking was going into a character
assassination where you were saying not
you in particular i don't even know
remember what because i was such such an
in in i was so trembling almost
you were trembling were you trembling
were you scared come on man
um calling me a coward
weak
spineless
um
yeah and my only defense to that is that
i just have my own way of dealing with
the world you know i mean because i
um grew up in such a traumatic childhood
i you know
i try to be passive and i try to not i
mean i'm afraid of confrontation as
everyone knows i'll be honest with you
we could swap frozen nation in here in a
heartbeat and he'd fee he just host this
show it's the same thing hey frozen you
want to go uh live in los angeles you
want to be a tiger belly you want to be
a tiger by the guy
i mean everyone else has
it's possible
you know
you take that back roy i'm just
i'm just joking she looks like a woman
of virtue i'm just joking
i was in terms of my character and um
you know
i said to brian days after that assault
um
that
yeah i know that was an assault
that assault would be like physical
right yeah beating you up yeah i'm going
to be your friend his friend um
did you guys speak out on the phone or
yeah we just yeah and he apologized he
said yeah he did apologize but um
yeah i mean he doesn't expect you to be
his friend yeah it's not it's done um
but you know that being said also i'll
never i don't have any i would never say
anything bad about him i think that he
is
one of the funniest people i've ever met
in my life
he's funny i really do um and can can i
give some context to to that card and we
definitely
admit straight up we definitely need to
handle that he'll admit
he'll admit
the way two
adults should have handled that
the context behind that is
is
i don't i i never talk about this stuff
ever
the our podcast's usually fun we don't
talk about you know the negative stuff
that i deal with brian was we talking
about you guys talked about us what do
you mean we've heard you know where the
the negativity that i deal with
everybody gets stuff on reddit everybody
in this room i don't know if you guys do
you you guys
yeah i'm sure klyla does we all do you a
woman in the space
huh
he's sticking up for women in this space
bro
what
what's wrong royce
do you not do you not
stick up for women in the space
he's such a [ __ ] liar he's
he's this phony
this this why i don't like the la comic
stuff i don't like it's this phony i
want to be on a pilot [ __ ] you know
what i mean it's it's this
it's this
a woman in this he just repeats stuff
that he hears bro hey brendan schaub
you're a cte parrot
you you walk the way other comics walk
you're not funny and now you're trying
to pivot from being a real [ __ ]
womanizer which is
that's what everybody said about you not
me
to now women in this space what does
that mean
oh by the space he means getting women
into his truck oh yeah that's true
so
there's a difference the only space is
[ __ ] between brandon's head there's
nothing in there bro what is wrong with
him
between hate
and then straight evil toxic criminal
behavior
and 40 for six years i've dealt with
this
now if you want to criticize
my comedy the podcast so be it that's
the internet that's it then why are you
suing people
you're you're showing somebody
right now
for it
and you send bent pixels which has
happened to us and happen to other
people to come and copyright claims
stuff so they don't insult you and their
last special the one on showtime which
is hilarious not when you think about
this you bribed your fans remember the
cbd was that's what it was it was cbd
company to give him a free product on
imdb come on dude don't even pretend
like that that you don't care that you
do that because people do it all the
time
and and you go after them
that's what we sign up for but when it
crosses over into harassment of my
family
death threats my kids going for sponsors
companies that i work with my business
that's that's where it gets dicey
so the
and it would have to get so dicey to the
point where look and i do agree there is
some [ __ ] like you know going people
sponsors [ __ ] gay you shouldn't do
that [ __ ]
threat threatening people's lives is
[ __ ] bad you shouldn't do that [ __ ]
but what i don't understand is how you
make the jump to when all that horrible
stuff is happening just like you know
who has that demeanor that bobby lee guy
bobby lee's the guy that's the
mastermind behind he's the guy he's the
evil genius
that's the thing i don't understand does
he think bobby lee's like butters and
he's professor chaos at nighttime like
that's the only thing i can think of
like bobby lee is the higher power yes
it was me brendan it was it was me all
along
my team gets notified on remember that
ending it made no sense you kidnapped
his music
like you scarred your daughter for life
and you're gonna have the undertaker
like i don't know rape her or something
yeah it was weird just to make a point
yeah just to make a point against a
business rival
because i'm not on social media and it's
or sure well not in any accounts people
know as hell not on red ah um
better than these forums and the reason
i'm not on there it's not because i
think i'm better than social media i
don't need it of course i knew i'm a
comic i'm not on it because it hurts my
feelings
sorry it's very funny when you say
things like that right
all that stuff i don't do well with it
it was so toxic comedy
you're entrusting
a team
to report back to you
and when you hear from that team you're
taking you're receiving it as gospel
this must be accurate information that
i'm receiving from these guys yes so
this is how we get here good question
yeah so this wasn't a question
she made a statement what an excellent
question that you didn't have that's the
statement get here so
hate uh again hate i understand there's
a lot to hate on
but again when it crosses over in a
criminal and this other stuff okay but
who are these twos's team
and they get notified and they get
notified because a member of that group
is abusing a six-year-old child with
autism
and then the reddit moderator gets
affected and they start talking so then
they look into it and that's how we get
here and they look into it and uh they
go hey let you know
one of the six accounts that has done
most the posting is associated with with
typing most of posting is it stress
shaded
oh we go back the whole thing right the
whole thing was a a mess yeah we have to
go back the whole thing most of the
poston most the poston
this is my favorite brendan shaw thing
it's just the brendan shawbisms
all right let's see here
by the way somebody commented a brendan
defender was like you guys claim to be
all about comedy but you called them
george carlton and i wrote was like new
around here huh
let's be your first time yeah that's how
we get here and they look into it and uh
they go hey
let you know
one of the six accounts that has done
most the posting most of posting
i told you man i love it it's my
favorite thing about brandon if you're
watching this give me a mouse to post it
in the comments thanks
i want to see most of poston
is associated with with tiger bells so
shot and then that's the one you caught
most of the posters
most supposed to shock you know what he
sounds like remember remembering joe
dirt like the the hillbilly guy from the
yeah
now with all the
toxic hate everything that i get yeah
this awful stuff
to i expect that from people i don't
know when i found out it was somebody
that i know yeah
i don't think brendan understands that
people people are it's not that he's a
bad comic because let's face it there's
a lot of bad comics like
people coming up that are first-time
comics are not going to be good and you
know what the truth of the matter is
some of the time they become good and
some of the time they don't i think the
p the reason people make fun of brendan
is is that he is a bad comic who
leapfrogged a whole bunch of other
comics because of who he knows
and we heard the stories of him like
parking up front at the comedy store
right in his raptor truck right where
people who've been there who are
actually you know making something so
it's kind of pretty big or whatever have
to go park in the back and he gets a
showtime special because of who he knows
and because he used to be a ufc fighter
not because he's a comic it's not that
you're a bad comic brandon because i
know you watch these but you say you
don't but you're lying it's not that
you're a bad comic brandon you are a bad
comic
there's a lot of bad comics there's a
lot of bad everything people starting
out aren't always good you know and
you're already behind the eight ball
because of the the you know the brain
being jello but you know on the kind of
your brain's being mush
kind of scrambled eggs head
and kind of
but but it's just
it's because you're so arrogant it's
because
you you you think you deserve to be
where you are and of course the only
reason you're doing this is because they
were trying to make somebody else happy
i mean look even in this even in this
little interview that we saw what did we
see we see bobby saying saying things
like yeah you said you were going to
bring this up to rogan so even you're
saying that he is the dawn he is the
boss he is the guy that puts people
where they are
but that and that's where the
aggressiveness came from but is it true
that's why i'm here
um i think this is not helpful because
this happened a week and a half ago when
in fact
this drama if we're going to talk about
contacts started in january and i think
while i really appreciate you being here
i truly believe you're
a guy who cares for his family i fee i
do believe you feel you're on the back
foot here
um and
you know you feel like your livelihood
is under attack i understand
the hurt all around that appreciate it
but
there is a lot more context
to what you guys are talking about in
context it's fun a week and a half ago
and
if it's okay with you because i don't
want there to be any confusion moving
forward i'd like to
start from the very beginning and just
get to the god honest truth because if
we don't do this
in a systematic way of when it started
and how did we end up here
the start with uh when i was notified of
the reddit group what do you want to
start no the start with a trash tuesday
podcast okay okay what's trash tuesday
podcast that's where she started trying
to remember telling a story oh yeah of
her friend okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're right right because i mean that
but here's where it gets conflicted is
those are almost two separate things
but they're not
apples and oranges no apples and apples
apples and chocolate milk no no apples
and blow jobs maybe
certain jobs in the truck yeah and i
understand that and i and i respect you
and we can talk about this so we get to
the end of it when it goes to the reddit
group
that's where the that call came from and
then th this this stuff that we're
talking about with trash tuesday
and
if i if i had a time machine and i could
go back you'd probably tell your younger
self not to get punched in the head so
much that's what i do get a time machine
please whatever you do stop letting them
punch you in the head either learn some
defense
or quit soon
i would have called
the reason we're here is because i
didn't handle this well
and i'll say this right now and i'll get
back to that trash tuesday stuff
let's say and i'm not saying this any
facet i truly believe neither of you
have anything to do with this reddit
group maybe someone on your team had or
not
i'm just saying from my perspective like
too okay yeah yeah and you can too
because my team is here and i that's
fine this is my family yeah so if you're
coming to me saying you're not
responsible but your team is you're
coming for my family i've been with
these guys for eight years i'm with you
clyde i'm with you and i would love for
you guys so he's still he's still trying
to push this
this that it's the team thing right but
he's still trying to take some heat off
i do like that she's going no i don't
even give me that [ __ ] and he's
immediately backing down no no i'm not
saying it i mean i am saying it is but
i'm not saying but i'm not saying it
here
and that is why i'm here and that is why
i'm here okay but that's why i'm here so
you know wait go ahead okay so
let's let's
you have your own timeline in your head
of how this went down and i have my own
timeline and while i want to believe
those two things are separate this is
the timing is very suspicious
but it's i also kind of want to just
interject real quick on on your show
bobby you should be let you should be
allowed to interject whenever you want
it's your show all right um
they're not separate to me because um
you know during the conversation right
when you guys called me you and brian
right the
the trash tuesday thing did come up in
that because why did you and i talked
about that that stuff before all this
though bobby
when i get into the weeds can i just
present a timeline so i don't want there
to be confusion she is she is feisty she
is feisty
if we're really here to talk about the
truth i'd like the opportunity to just
start from the beginning please do and
you know you were trying to block it now
he's going please do but you saw how
long he was trying to block not that
part filibuster what you're doing is uh
well as you would call it phil busting
phil busting he's rand pauling yeah you
know if at any point you feel what i'm
saying is truly unfair and unjustified
you can interject and say kaleida let me
clarify on that but i have written it
down this is something that has taken so
much of my mental space and clarity and
i don't want to what are these
i am sick of these california words
i am really sick of my mental space in
my shut up
california words we're all [ __ ] here
extra vowels the accent on top
what was that frozen
i said uh royce your shouting is really
affecting my mental space okay shut up
i'm gonna affect your mental face we're
so dumb theo comes off as this smart one
[Laughter]
brendan you're too dumb for california
bud live like this mean either me and i
know you don't and and again if i can go
back and finish this thought is when
if i could if i had a time machine if i
could turn back time
if i could find a brain
go back i would call you directly thank
you for saying because you and i don't
know each other well i don't know well
and when i came hold on guys feel bad
for the guy yelling at you wearing a
brand new fitted cap and a rolex
to you
and i'll tell you this right now anybody
out there if you're going to go out
kalyala you better be ready to go you
are
not to be underestimated you're very
[ __ ] smart and
dude and i and i told you this when when
we buttering her up because what's about
to come out it's not good huh [ __ ]
yeah i said you should be a lawyer
you're as good as you are in pocket you
should be a goddamn lawyer that brendan
but but but you're you're you're
impressed by jingling keys like i'm
sorry
but i'm just setting the bar here
yeah brendan you're so dumb like all
right my cat will play with a laser
pointer for about three minutes and then
get bored and then get oh this is i
can't touch whatever this is so forget
it you would last longer
with my laser pointer than my cat would
yeah
then if i could redo it i would call you
direct and this would have been solved
so easily
also with the other information i had i
don't get in the weeds i don't throw
anybody under the bus notice he's a
parody she said in the weeds so you know
what he does he copies what of course he
but he does that with everything yeah
he's just yeah
with other information i had from a
person we all know in here
uh
so it's not gonna be theo
the information from the person cause
theo and bobby are cool who's another
person they all know and it's not rogan
we know it's not rogan so we think of
the crew who's who in the world
whitney cummings that's actually not bad
i'm going joey diaz no joe diaz doesn't
get if joey doesn't get involved in any
of this [ __ ] joey isn't going to get
involved what are you talking about he
was literally trying to extort 20 grand
for mike david or he's going to crack
him in the head with a baseball bat that
was pretty funny forgot about that
you're right
and by the way n jewels for some reason
also the wife oh crack over the [ __ ]
baseball bat right in the mouth and
you're like i mean we're just so we're
assaulting spouses now we're just we're
just hitting spouses with baseball bats
i don't know him that well and i don't
know you that well you don't know
anybody that will
that'll book you after this
that information that information come
at me at the same time that the trash
tuesday and all the stuff coming it was
too it was like this perfect world win
right but if
not whirlwind hey hey
whirlwind whirlwind
not a whirlwind whirlwind a whirlwind i
would have talked to you before and you
gave me the context i went that makes so
much sense
why didn't you and i have an idea here
and hear me out here just tell me out
here real quick
why didn't you talk to them before
having sending pitbull brian callan to
rip their throat out out of curiosity
this we'll get to the part where she is
not he is trying to whatever she's
trying to say she's having none of it
yeah
i give her credit
but you're right she he she wants to say
something that's making him like who's
filibuster that information is then
weaponized
against me to people like rogan and
whitney and shaw what name whitney
frozen you might be right frozen you did
a
you did a bang-up job on that one yeah
it's in people that are very influential
in the podcast space
and is whitney cummings influential in
the podcast we stop calling things
spaces yeah
first off yes thank you and secondly
that's when i when i think of space
right like oh this space i'm thinking
like when you're at a hotel
and you go and there's like that little
work room and it's really nice you think
oh what a nice space yeah it's a nice
little space stop calling every social
circle a space right one of those pods
that they give you like in a hotel yeah
a new language everybody uses raging
which wasn't fair to you the character
assassination that took place
assassination so she's just as dumb no
no i get no you know what he's rubbing
off on her yeah that's what it is he's
he's wet he's
he's rubbing off on her okay i meant
like okay that's what started all this
that's what started this whole fiance
trying to rub off on her in the truck
yeah i think
you underestimated how much information
was actually i give her you know why
give her a break because spanish is her
first language brendan's first language
is english they're gonna get back to me
from these people um but again i really
just wanna
take just 10 minutes go ahead yep well
it's been 20.
to offer a timeline and if this doesn't
work
it doesn't work i just
really just want to have a moment of
[ __ ]
clarity in all of this
um
i also want to add that in therapy in
every session i hear better part of you
is not the total of you and i do believe
you're a great father who loves his
family oh my god with therapies you guys
are comics
what is this what is this new [ __ ]
breeze psychologically an emotional
circle jerk dude [ __ ] stop this is
really sad
and you have regular human feelings that
get triggered um you have fears you have
all of these triggers you offer empathy
in that way um so in
i wish this i wish i was funnier and i
could like
offer levity but i just don't i feel
like [ __ ] about it um
so here's what i have
and you know hearsay and rumors are
super damaging and i just want to put
that all to rest please do even this
brendan i would have loved to do
privately me
okay
i wouldn't i get get the numbers out of
it right
might as well right three yeah
um that hurt my feelings yeah um it hurt
mine as well um but we'll get there
we'll get there so when i went to showed
up to 83 podcast
this wasn't even in
our world it wasn't in our view our mind
you know what i mean and i don't know
him and i have no ill will towards right
i don't know him but from my
understanding from talking to mutual
friends of ours that's what he does
right yeah but you know we had done the
podcast yeah but we had done that
podcast before many times before he's
done ours him and his wife
by the way can i say thank you so much
to taper for when he made the last clip
when we played the h3 when he blurred
out hilda's face
for no reason for no reason he blurted
out to help him and we were being
thanked in the clip section for it that
is hilarious right [ __ ] hillary
nobody asked him to do that nobody asked
him he did it on his own that was so
funny
and after i uploaded i read it goes oh
by the way i blurred her face and i
looked at him like [ __ ] that that's
really really funny yeah
really they're lovely and i don't know
people are lovely i don't know them you
know um and you know it wasn't in our
you know and even on the drive back from
there we just
were in we were in
a state of shock okay i'm going to get
to the explanation
new segment never happening again
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah hopefully that's not a new
statement
because
they just said the title of this file on
my computer is the
job spectacle extravaganza
but then also so apologize for that
we've talked about before
trust me i've been to therapy over this
stuff that's also another reason i'm on
social media so
back up back up we missed something we
missed something
slash what guild belly today if approved
you'll get ten dollars off your phone oh
they slipped that live version
hey man i i don't that's stuff i don't
hate on
that's smart that's smart i would do
that too
yeah
okay so on january 25th a trash tuesday
episode is released where annie and i
talk about a nameless comic who hit on
us and for me um
that story that i told took place seven
years ago long time ago you referring to
dms right
which i own and was completely stupid
thank you never should have done okay
right
okay so he admitted it
yeah i'll defend myself like i own that
and that and
that was not right and i've definitely
checked and you apologize and i
apologize
but then also so apologize for that
we've talked about before
trust me i've been to therapy over this
stuff that's also another reason i'm on
social media so i don't engage that's
the main reason he's on social media in
any of that stuff
so
i've learned from that
as far as the annie stuff goes that's
where i do have to defend myself okay i
have to you know
you guys didn't say my name
right i get or you but you
is that a word well because you guys
said said it was a really unfunny kind
of comedian so i i mean we all knew yeah
right away that it was me and that's i
think what
i have a guilty conscience
alluding asian is a word but not for
this yeah that's more shin yeah
she
had
the line was what am i gonna do suck
your unfunny dick and
i mean
[Music]
unfunny penis that's a good line
and then i i came back as far as me
but she uh again i didn't see it but as
far as she's saying i i asked her to
walk my car or give her a ride no i i
think that
i you know i cannot speak for her yeah i
can only tell you
i'm saying i can only tell you what was
said on that particular point and again
if that's how she feels she's validated
feel like that
and i'm about to feel like that happened
okay that's a situation you would have
to talk to her about but i'm going to
get back to the podcast itself yeah the
what was said was that there was a guy
he was unfunny i came back with oh
that's a big clue and
that's something about a peach emoji
and then but my thing with it by the way
this is what i was taught
we talked we talked about this off air
when in new york we're talking about
this with some good people and it's like
this is the thing that like
this shouldn't be a sacrilegious thing
to make fun of another comic like comics
do this look man i understand why like
i'm not an idiot like oh you have to
work with these people you're touring
places you're gonna be with them
podcasting i get it
but
there's this like oh yeah you don't make
fun of other comics you know or you not
that don't make fun of it but you don't
say they're not funny you don't
criticize your material they're awesome
and it's like
this seems like this was like oh you
don't do that and it's like but why not
right now people do it all the time that
guy do you think that's nice oh no it's
not nice it's not nice
is it true
so that's what we're the goal now is to
be nice comedians l.a comedians [ __ ]
suck
hey man that wasn't very nice of you
that rose joke wasn't very nice
i'm just thinking patrice o'neil being
alive now like that's one thing i can
imagine
but i didn't say your name
but but come on you said the initials
were bs and then you jumped and said it
was bob saget
you did this this is the this is the
[ __ ] this is the girl thing that
she's doing it's like when we pass a
really aggressively do yeah yeah the b
shop now that's too obvious brendan s
yes
exactly what that is but it's it's hang
on one second brendan let me let me ask
you this
if we're having this discussion about
something that happened in the past and
we're having a giggly little girl talk
where is the crime in that there's no
crime you can do whatever you want right
i have no issue with that go ahead okay
yeah no issue with it all right i'm just
saying you have a big issue because you
just asked is it nice
is that nice that's all i have gone to
you and said if i could go back if i had
known that how bad you were
at comedy tiny little giggly girl talk
was going to spiral into this now he's
going to say that this isn't the reason
why when this is the reason why i would
have wired my mouth shut
but in my heart of hearts while you may
think it's not nice and now i admit not
the nicest thing to say it was just an
anecdote no stop stop stop
all of these people stop all of that i
hate all of these stop all of this is
there anyone not being nice and you
can't be nice and you're being nice and
rich foss went on o a every day and they
made fun of how [ __ ] stupid he was
for his entire [ __ ] almost entire
professional career and the guy was best
friends with all these people shut the
[ __ ] up i have heard comics say some
horrendous
things to each other patrice o'neill
threw a [ __ ] phone book at kevin hart
and said here you need that maybe you
could find someone who anybody in there
will be funnier than what you're doing
right now that was something he said to
kevin hart who turned out to be one of
the biggest comics alive right now but
that's how it is man that's how it
[ __ ] is and this like i should have
been nice is the reason we're gonna get
more brendan jobs because everyone's
[ __ ] afraid
to say you're unfunny you're unfunny
brendan you're not a funny [ __ ]
person i think comedy's subjective
no he is objectively not funny
sure so that was i didn't think you see
his bit about mexican food though yeah
which one his entire special yeah i saw
it you didn't like the i like the point
where he was like pick up the gun
[ __ ] ripping off keenan
uh
keenan should have a showtime spell you
will you would not agree that keenan
should have a showtime special way
before brendan ever had one right
so i skipped over to this park because
this is another timeline that
the ladpole said was good get into okay
okay that i don't want to bring up
that's not fair to you guys or or
anybody we can get into that what is
that other thing yeah we can get into
that
the other day hold on let me let me
actually yeah probably let me let's
assume that it's the same old narrative
of me being a gold digger and stealing
money from bobby
hmm
it yeah you know that spoke about this
and you told me oh yes i mean let's
let's be real that is an old tired story
bobby call your accountants
okay
here's the truth i'm not a controlling
gold digger bobby go ahead and talk
matter okay
i don't even really need to i don't i
don't i don't need to know this i i i
know it's
okay the the only reason i'm here was to
bring up the red thing and show you guys
information no no no no no no no no no
no no no you don't get to go on somebody
else's show this is that arrogance that
he has you don't get to go on somebody
else's show after what you [ __ ] did
to this guy which was undeserved and
then go no no but i only came here to
talk about reddit
carry on and move just keep going okay
i'm almost done i promise
we're already in march
okay
oh yeah april all right the producer
laughs like this is pretty funny
playing a few more
okay so we ended with i don't want to
get to have to get nasty with her but if
i have to i'll play that game you were
alluding to stuff you heard from
somebody about me being a gold digging
[ __ ] and um
the other stuff the the cheating right
allegedly which was whitney cummings um
wendy cummings
bobby says
calls you and says
hey dude i saw
you know that's when you guys discuss i
saw those text messages years ago this
is all when i was
and you did hit on her she will not be
saying your name anymore but you need to
let this go right you guys agreed to
that correct correct okay
um
in the next coming week childish
high school
drama
these are comics
i don't understand this look all com let
me explain something to you here ain't
no one white knighting for her either
all comics [ __ ] each other while on the
road that's [ __ ] part of life right i
mean if you're going to be a comic
because being a [ __ ] rock star right
you're traveling around you're big
enough when you're traveling [ __ ] like
that's going to happen
it doesn't it's just like being a rock
star no no i'm not saying in the
end it's just like being a rock is like
being a rock star weeks however i'm
starting to see screenshots on instagram
of dms of um your cute little friend
mark
confirming that you wanted to expose me
is that correct no no no no you read
that wrong he wanted to expose himself
to me
or vice versa
honestly any either or he said open bob
bob's in vagine i believe was a dm
i didn't see them you know
but
well no i went to mark and said dude
you're making things way worse for me
okay because he's trying to defend me i
went you're not defending me you're
making okay i gotta get to this next
time stamp
which is
here
for two and a half how is this possible
then i said let me get this straight
you're telling me that while
investigating a child abuse case the
feds were like yeah let's put this
beaten baby case to rest and pursue
shobs online harassment instead
the argument was super heated
i said brendan you can audit my [ __ ]
my pet's [ __ ] my mom's [ __ ] and
you'll find nothing
plus why are you doing all of this
over a story i told on my show
i never said your name you said that
can't be true
i said roll the tapes listen go back you
but you did though stop see again
i'm not on your side there back open
your ears and hear it for yourself that
was april 24th
now i'm going to go to here see that's
what they were talking about and then
okay so let's can i go he's going to
respond can i go where's your timeline
where's your piece of paper
timeline
[Laughter]
one time only yeah
[Music]
all this stems back to all that stuff
it's all a place of fear it's all a
place of fear because we talk about
reddit and that stuff and the harassment
promise you mine's different that
i know i look tough and all that that
stuff hurts my feeling that's why i'm
not in social media it's not because i
think i'm better than anybody it was
because the hitting on thing you said it
earlier that was another reason you said
like that that stuff is horrendous
horrendous i believe horrendous
so when that team looks into it and i
notified that it's tiger belly
i'm so upset
now you guys saying you have nothing to
do with it right so but at the time i
was so upset because you've always been
nice to me okay i'm gonna say this i
don't think bobby has anything to do
with it i don't think she has anything
to do with the reddit thing i don't
think anybody on their team has any do
the reddit thing i really don't i don't
know what they could have possible how
they could have gotten that information
i'm really trying to wonder
again like you said unless they have
somebody at reddit and even then like
that would be i mean that's possible
but they could have somebody right you
know what i mean if you're famous enough
but that would be
i doubt there's a lot of people that
work at reddit that are big brendan job
fighters there's a lot of people that
live on this planet that are big branded
shop fans you've always been nice to me
we don't know each other but you've
always been nice to me so i was so upset
because if it's someone random that's
whatever
that's what they're gonna do but
somebody that i know i was so upset that
i thought i'm not even gonna talk to him
about it or ask him about it what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna panic
i expect it from somebody i don't know
but somebody that i assume i know
that's where this stem first couple
minutes here from
the anger i cannot emphasize how upset i
was and hurt and deeply hurt because
again
i don't think you guys have anything to
do with it
but where are you hold up but hold on
i have i have the proof here's the thing
did you wish your briefcase i don't need
where's your proof i got to give her
credit
yeah where's your briefcase with the
proof
she's actually funnier than him which
sucks i know but she is though i mean
he's not that funny but she's funnier
than brendan's job
yeah i don't need a briefcase i wish i
could laugh at that yeah i don't have a
briefcase i have it all on my phone the
reason i can't send it to you because
the ongoing investigation
it's an ongoing investigation
mean reddit posts
unfortunately but hold on he says it's a
team you can't go on reddit it's all
taped off right now it's a crime scene
is it being investigated by the police
or by your little internal team yeah
because that's then then it can you can
talk about it yeah
either you can or you can't
i can't on the investigation for the
child abuse thing for there's six counts
on there that you're talking about
pedophiles you're talking about horrible
[ __ ]
okay it's bigger than me
but they're gonna that's gonna be dealt
with
my thing for you doing the tiger but see
giving up
who's going after him or showing has
nothing to do with the other stuff
you're colluding them both so you don't
have to
you don't have to show anything do
whatever you want with this whatever you
want i
i'm good man it's horrible and i want to
squash between us do what and let me get
this out bob i know you want to talk
on your show i'll show you
the stuff that i have
you guys figure out what you want to do
with it
this is wait wait wait wait wait but you
just said you couldn't because it was an
ongoing investigation but now you're
saying you can
i'm sorry who are you working with the
green acres police department
oh is officer barbrady there
is there a pathway
aside from that like you know
um
to be in terms of
right what we do look at here is army ml
here
well let's see what he says well he had
sent
okay so and then
you're you don't stop for you know what
i'm saying but you deny then that you
felt under attack by the girls and that
you had to double down and create this
reddit drama like you denied that i
swear on my kids okay so you you're my
kids you're insisting that's two
separate um things and not correct not
associated with any facets they are
connected that's [ __ ] the only
reason you jumped to bobby lee into the
tiger belly crew was because they had
just talked [ __ ] about you
that's 100 connected
100
i'm sure this isn't the end of this
but this this is the end of the current
i don't think any new stuff has come up
yet
but we will keep an eye on it for you
guys we promise we promise we will be on
100 brighton watch we watch brendan so
you don't have to this whole thing is so
unbelievably gay